[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie this week on
arrow it's Christmas and everyone
deserves a present we found out who the
real Big Bad is and Barry Allen became
the flash since it's gonna be on break
for the next five weeks I'm gonna be
doing bonus videos in the meantime be
sure to subscribe to get them also be
doing content for the flash as well
since there were so many big moments
let's do our top ten and then I'll do my
review number ten STAR Labs the particle
accelerator malfunctions and given the
riots that were going on when it was
working it's unlikely that they're going
to continue with that line of technology
leaving them free in the future to
experiment with more things like say
cyborgs number nine the Solomon Grundy
poem a lot of you caught the Sarah scold
Solomon running out last week this week
they went one step further by reading
the poem out loud
twice solomon grundy born on a monday
christened on a tuesday married on a
wednesday took ill on thursday grew
worse on friday died on the saturday
buried on sunday that was the end of
solomon grundy by the way he is
definitely not dead number eight the
entity known as bola City so Barry let's
felicity know that he is totally down to
go on a date and he will never be late
it was a nice nod to the flash and it
kind of teases that they'll be dating in
the future obviously because Grant
Gustin is not going to guest star on
arrow every single week Oliver and
Diggle will probably just tease Felicity
about her and Barry's relationship week
to week the other four anything about
that exchanges that Barry lets Felicity
know that he's not just jealous of
Oliver for getting to be around her all
the time he's jealous of her because she
gets to be around the arrow all the time
number seven Slade's new powers the cool
thing about all this is that he doesn't
even realize he has superpowers now
until he starts snapping guns in half
like their pencils and punching holes
and dudes this was easily one of my
favorite revenge moments on any show all
season long number six you should look
into compressible micro fabric Barry
totally teas not only Oliver's Green
Arrow mask but his flash suit as well if
anyone is wondering the crater's have
actually said that his flash outfit
won't exactly be like it is in the comic
books but it will probably be something
plain-looking made out of compressible
micro fabric Barry also has this really
keen eye for use of color he grills
Oliver on his choice of green for
costume this attention to color detail
is going to be very important in the
future number five good thing you have a
rat problem Barry Waites Oliver up with
poison it was funny and a little bit
terrifying
the same moment it's good to know that
rat poison works as a blood thinner but
I would check with your doctor before
trying this at home
number four Barry left a present for you
Barry leaves Oliver is green arrow mask
and wraps it in newspaper and it has
this red flash on the corner but it also
teases Oliver's feature as Green Arrow
he's not quite there yet he still has to
defeat Slade and brother blood before he
can really become this true hero but he
is definitely going to be Green Arrow by
the end of this season number three
Roy has powers Roy has all of the same
powers that solomon grundy and Slade
have super-strength SuperSpeed and super
durability a lot of you been wondering
if he's going to become speedy so here's
how it happened in the comic books first
he was Green Arrow's sidekick and was
called speedy then he joined Teen Titans
and became Arsenal and then he joined
the Justice League and became red arrow
because they used the red arrows in
previous episodes I'm thinking these are
just going to skip to Roy calling
himself a version of red arrow but
Oliver Felicity and Diggle are probably
going to tease him by calling him speedy
he'll actually be spending the rest of
this season learning to control his
powers as seen in the new teaser number
two
Slade is the new Big Bad the creator
said that in a recent interview that
after Slade found shado dead on the
island and vowed revenge things did not
get better between him and Oliver and
remember Oliver had said that he killed
everyone on the island that had taken
the miracle serum so at some point he's
probably going to try and kill Slade
during one of the flashbacks and my
number one moment Barry Allen becomes
the flash as predicted Barry was infused
with the Speed Force the storm in his
lab were a nice nod to the classic flash
birth story but if you were confused the
particle accelerator basically tore hole
in space-time and the lightning that
struck him was the Speed Force it wasn't
just regular lightning the yellow and
red liquids rising up were a nice visual
reference to what's coming and even
though the Creator said that he won't be
wearing red spandex remember he was
talking to Oliver about compression
fabric and remember what a big deal
color is to him but let me know what
your favorite moment was was it watching
Barry Allen become the flash was it
seeing Slade again I have to say my
favorite moment totally flash
self-explanatory not only is this
episode my favorite episode of arrow so
far it's actually my favorite mid-season
finale of any show all season long I
really feel like agents of shield is
trying to get to the point where arrow
is now slate I can't believe how awesome
it is that he's back on the show he is
going to make the best big bat it's big
because his fight against Oliver is
personal and the best villains have the
most personal connections with the hero
just think about Sherlock and Moriarty
during series two but just to go in
Reverse a little bit starting with Barry
Allen becoming the flash so not only did
the sound design kind of provide this
really anticipatory mood like you knew
something special was gonna happen but I
give arrow the biggest high-five for
totally paying off moments like this but
let me know what you think and if you
have an episode of a favorite television
show that you like better than this
episode of arrow let me know what it is
like I said until arrow comes back I'll
be doing regular bonus videos for that
as well as the flash be sure to
subscribe to get them right now you can
actually click here to get last week's
episode of arrow and you can click here
to get my breakdown of the Doctor Who
Christmas special thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you